turning off power was the worst idea
ever oh oh oh oh pills can I get those
pills please please pills
I see pills please there we go okay I
can't see I can't see I can't see
anything easy listen listen listen
aah oh my god I'm flying blind aah I
fell into the hole oh thank you progress
oh these are padded rooms padded cells
oh my oh oh
darkness darkness darkness battery huh I
found it I have one health
I have one health one
oh yeah oh yeah oh come on come on
oh my god please kill him can you not
die yeah yeah yes yes oh I didn't even
do anything
it just pushed me seriously into legit
like that okay whatever no no I can't do
this I can't deal with this just stay
right there stay right there
now I've got